like the way you spoon it to me
[Laughter]
hi welcome back to chasing our roots i'm
vanessa and today we're hanging out with
chef erica lacer from diva dog so we're
going to be doing our apple pie bread
pudding and i use a liquor that has like
apple flavoring to it for the sauce i've
had that before not have that
combination okay well good i would say
that it's an easy dish but it depends on
the type of cook you are so i am really
excited to make this dessert with you so
let's go ahead and get into it we have
five eggs here right how to mix that up
a little bit so we're gonna put the milk
but i'm not gonna put all the milk i'm
kind of reserved a little bit so we have
the cream here that we're gonna add in
so my storefront i loved it was like all
brick on the inside but it was like i
was there every day couldn't get away
that's not what i wanted to do i wanted
to have a business where i had the
freedom to still be creative so has your
menu or recipes changed because you're
not using a storefront anymore you're on
a food truck so i had to condense my
menu a little bit so i just cut it down
to two which is my diva dog and the
alligator sausage as well as just some
other items that i have of course the
bread pudding we're gonna put a little
bit of sugar and i always put more sugar
than i probably need and then we have
our vanilla cinnamon and then we just
mix all of this together to make our
custard i'm the kind of cook that
doesn't really measure so i'm i'm going
to try to go buy a recipe i just know
it's going to come out the way i like it
i put love into my food and when i'm in
a great mood my food tastes even better
go as close as you can without taking
off too much of the apple just take it
cut the sides off and i'm a girl that
hates to waste anything i take
everything off so why do you choose to
use granny smith apples instead of like
a red delicious apple gritty sweet is
pretty much a traditional apple that you
use if you made apple pie apple pie and
bread pudding like typically aren't
supposed to go together but you have
that custardy style flavor soaked in
with this baked gummy bread so let's add
in the bread this is nice and moist
right here and so now we can add in our
apples that we cut okay and i like that
it's like the chunks are not too big so
this definitely smells like the
beginning of fall like the seasons
changing i mean it works year-round for
my customers i use my hot dog buns like
it was a moment where i had ordered too
many buns for an event i can't throw
this bread away like i just cannot do it
and so i grind it all up and kind of
made bread pudding and it tastes better
than when i was using french bread and
this is kind of like a technique i
learned when i was in culinary school so
we're going to pour that in there i make
it the same way i was taught as a little
girl and make it now we're going to put
in the oven at 350. so when i'm at home
it's just pretty much putting cream in a
pot thicken it up with some cornstarch
adding sugar to it and as much liquor as
you want to and drizzle that right on
top um i put on the stove brought it to
a bowl and it kind of reduced a little
bit so we'll add like a little bit of
corn starch to it so this is just going
to thicken it up just a little bit more
so it'll be more pudding-like and put a
little bit more cinnamon sugar and we're
going to taste this here and for me i
still need more sugar
and so now we're ready for the good part
that
nice apple smells
definitely going to help everything come
together this is going to be so good so
it's nice and good so we put that back
on the sofa a little bit i'm chefing it
up you can really see that it's like
really thickening up yeah nice thickness
to where it just comes off really really
smooth on your spoon spatula whatever
you're using this is gonna be good to go
right here i like this consistency right
here so we're going to put that in the
bowl and watch how pudding like it comes
out so we'll just add a little bit of
the apples here sauce is nice and ready
for us so let's go get the pudding okay
all right see that color nice and golden
it's like really crunchy is it you can
tell because it starts to kind of puff
up just like a little bit so i just kind
of take a butter knife and kind of dab
it in the middle just to make sure that
center is kind of cooking all the way
through what i want to do just to make
it pretty for presentation wise now i do
not do this on the truck pop that on the
plate look how beautiful that is wow you
can see like a definitive crust and then
like the gooeyness of the bread pudding
just take that sauce and you put it on
it however you want i think we still
have some cut apples over here
i present to you my cognac apple pie
bread pudding thank you so much chef
erica i am so excited to try this i'm
going to dig into this right now please
enjoy it
so we're going to go ahead and dive in
food perfect you can change the crunches
of the apples the crispy layer all the
moisture inside the bread pudding
cinnamon and the sugar it all comes
together and even that like hints of
cognac you can taste all of that passion
that she really puts into her food is so
so good yeah try it
it's funny because i don't like apple
pie but i like this
really good you guys have to just come
to new orleans and just try this for
yourself check out the bread pudding it
is so amazing here so that's it for us
here at diva dog thank you to chef erica
and her entire team for letting us come
hang out and thank you for watching
tasting our roots bye
[Music]
you